So today we're going to
continue our discussion
of enforcing modularity.
And in particular if you
remember last time we spent
a lot of time talking about --
Last time we spent a
lot of time talking
about how we can create a
virtual memory so that we can
have multiple programs running
on top of one piece of hardware
that all appear to
have a separate address
space or separate memory.
So, two lectures ago,
we talked about having
one module per computer.
And then last time we
talked about this notion
of wanting to have a module
per virtual computer.
And we saw this notion
of virtual memory.
OK, and now this time
what we're going to do
is we're going to talk
about the other piece
that our virtual computer needs,
which is a virtual processor.
OK, so the idea
that we want here
when we are designing
a virtual processor
is to create, have
our programs be
able to run on a single
physical processor,
but have different programs
be able to run as though they
were the only program that was
executing on that processor.
So we want the programs
to be written in a style
where the programmer
doesn't have
to be aware of the other
programs that are running
on the machine, but where
the machine creates sort
of a virtual processor for
each one of these programs
that's running so that each
program has its own sort of set
of instructions
that it executes.
And those instructions
appear to be
independent of all the other
programs that are running.
So in order to create this
illusion of a virtual processor
--
-- we are going to introduce
a very simple concept.
We're going to have each
program run in what's
known as a thread.
And thread is really short
for a thread of execution.
And a thread is just a
collection of all of the state
that we need in
order to keep track
of what one single
given program is doing
at a particular point in time.
So a thread is a collection
of the instructions
for the program that
the module is running,
as well as the current
state of the program.
In particular, it's the value of
the registers on the processor
including of particular import
for this lecture the program
counter and the stack pointer.
OK, so there's a bunch of
registers on the processor,
say, 32 registers,
and there also
are these special registers,
the program counter,
that keeps track of which
instruction is currently
being executed, and
the stack pointer which
keeps track of
where on the stack
values are currently being
pushed or popped from.
So these things combined
together with the stack
are really the things that
define one single thread.
So, and the way to
think about this
is if you think about a
program that's running,
you can really encapsulate
almost everything about what
that program is currently
doing by the instructions
that it has to execute, the
value of the registers that
are currently set
in the program,
and the state
that's on the stack.
Now, programs may
also have some sort
of data that's stored
in the global memory
in the global variables
our things that
are stored on the heap that have
been allocated via some memory
allocation call.
And so those things are
a part of the program
as well, although I don't
want to explicitly list them
as being a part
of a single thread
because if two
programs, as we'll see,
two programs can share
the same address space.
And if two programs are
sharing the same address space,
then they're going to share
those global variables,
the stuff that's stored on
the heap of the program.
So think of a thread as
these things, plus there
is some additional,
we'll call it a heap,
set of memory that may be
shared between several different
threads that are all running
within the same address space.
And I'll explain more
about that as we go.
OK, so as I said,
now what we want
is to create this illusion
that each one of these threads
has its own virtual processor
upon which it's running.
So how are we going
to accomplish that?
So if you think about
this for a second,
the way to accomplish
this is simply
to allow each one of
these, each thread
to update these
various registers,
push things onto
the stack, and then
to have some function
which we can call,
which will save all
of this current state
off for the current
thread that's executing,
and then load the state in for
another thread that might be
executing, and stop the
current thread from executing,
and start the new one executing.
So the idea is if you were
to look at a timeline of what
the processor was doing, and
if the processor is running
two threads, thread
one and thread two,
you would see that during
some period of time,
thread one would be running.
Then the computer
would switch over
and thread two
would start running,
and then again the
computer would switch,
and thread one
would start running.
So we are going to multiplex the
processor resource in this way.
So we have one processor that
can be executing instructions.
And at each point in
time, that processor
is going to be
executing instructions
from one of these two threads.
And when we switch in these
points in between threads,
we are going to have to save off
this state for the thread that
was running, and restore the
state for the thread that
is currently running.
OK, so that's a very
high-level picture
of what we're going to
be doing with threads.
And there's going to be a
number of different ways,
and that's what we're going to
look at through this lecture is
how we can actually
accomplish this switching,
how we decide when to switch,
and what actually happens
when this switch takes place.
OK, so we're going to look
at several different methods.
So the first thing
we're going to look at
is an approach called
cooperative scheduling,
or cooperative switching.
So in cooperative
switching, what happens
is that each thread
periodically decides
that it's done processing
and is willing to let
some other process run.
OK, so the thread calls a
routine that says I'm done;
please schedule another thread.
So, this cooperative
approach is simple,
and it's easy to think about.
In the grand scheme of
enforcing modularity
of creating this illusion
that each program really
has its own computer
that's running,
and where each program
gets to run no matter
what any other program
does, cooperative scheduling
has a bit of a
problem because if we
are doing cooperative
scheduling,
then one process can just
never call this function that
says I give up time to the
other processes running
on the system.
One module may just never
give up the processor.
And then we are in trouble
because no other module ever
gets to run.
So instead what we're
going to talk about,
the alternative to
this, is something
we call preemptive scheduling.
And in preemptive
scheduling, what
happens is some part of the
computer, say, the kernel,
periodically decides that
it forces the currently
running thread to
give up the processor,
and starts a new thread running.
And we'll see how
that works, OK?
I also want to
draw a distinction
between whether these threads
are running in the same address
space or in a different
address space,
or in a different address space.
OK, so we could, for example,
have these two threads, T1
and T2.
They might be running as a part
of a single, say, application.
So, for example, they
might be a part of a,
say for example, some computer
game that we have running.
So suppose we have a computer
game like, but let me just load
up my computer here.
Suppose we have a
computer game like
pick your favorite
computer game, say, Halo.
And we are running
Halo, and Halo
is going to consist
of some set of threads
that are responsible
for running this game.
So we might have one
main thread which,
what it does when it
runs is to simply update;
it repeats in a loop
over and over again,
wait for a little
while, check and see
if there's any user input,
update the state of the game,
and then, say for example,
redraw the display.
And because Halo is a
videogame that somebody
is staring at and
looking at, it needs
to update that
display at some rate,
say, once every 20
times a second in order
to create the illusion of
sort of natural animation
in the game.
So this wait step is
going to wait a 20th
of a second between every step.
OK, so this might be
one example of a thread.
But of course within Halo, there
may be multiple other threads
that are also running.
So there may be a thread
that's responsible for looking
for input over the
network, right,
to see if there is
additional data that's
arrived from the user, and from
other users that are remote
and updating the
state of the game
as other information comes in.
And there may be a third
thread that, say for example,
is responsible for doing
some cleanup work in the game
like reclaiming memory
after some monster that's
running around the game has
died and we no longer need
its state, OK?
So if we look at just this,
say, main thread within Halo,
as I said here we
can encapsulate
the state of this thread
by a set of registers,
say, R1 through Rn, as
well as a stack pointer
and a program counter.
And then, there
also will be a stack
that represents the
currently executing program.
So, for example,
the stack might,
if we just have entered
into this procedure,
it might just have
a return address
which is sort of
the address that we
should jump to when we're
done executing this Halo
program here.
And then finally, we
have a program counter
that points to this
sort of current place
where we are executing it.
So we might have started
off where we are just
executing the first instructions
here, the init instruction.
OK, so what we're
going to look at now
is this case where we
have a bunch of threads,
say for example, in Halo all
running within the same address
space.
So they're all part
of the Halo program.
They can all access the
global variables of Halo.
But we want to have
different threads
to do different operations
that this program may
need to take care of.
So we want each of these threads
to sort of have the illusion
that it has its own processor.
And then later we'll talk
about a set of programs,
say, that are running
in different address
And we'll talk about what's
different about managing
two threads, each of which is
running in a different address
space.
OK, so the very
simple idea that we're
going to introduce in order
to look at this situation
where we are going to
start off by looking
at cooperative scheduling
in the same address space.
We are going to introduce the
notion of a routine called
yield.
OK, so yield is going to
be the thing the currently
executing thread calls when it's
ready to give up the processor
and let another thread run.
So the thread is going
to run for a while
and then it's going
to call yield,
and that's going to allow
other threads to sort of do
their execution.
And this is cooperative
because if a program doesn't
call yield, then no other
program will ever be
allowed to run on the system.
So the basic idea is that
when a program calls yield,
what it's going to
do is exactly what I
described just a minute ago.
So yield is going to save the
state of the current thread,
and then it's going to --
-- schedule the next thread,
so pick the next thread to run
from all of the available
threads that are on the system.
And then it's going to
dispatch the next thread,
so it's going to
in particular setup
the state for the next thread
so that it's ready to run.
And it's going to jump into the
return address for that thread.
OK, so I want to take you guys
through a very simple example
of a program that has
multiple threads in it.
And we're going to have a
simple thread scheduler.
So, the thread
scheduler is the thing
that decides which
thread to run next.
And this thread
scheduler is going
to keep an array of
fixed size, call it
num_threads, that are all the
threads that are currently
running on the system.
It's going to have an integer
that is going to tell us
what the next thread to run is.
And then for every
one of our threads,
we're going to have
a variable that we
call me which is the ID of the
currently executing thread.
So, this is local to the thread.
OK so let's look at
an example of how
this might work with
this Halo thread
that we're talking about here.
OK, so suppose we
have a Halo thread.
And we'll call this the
main thread of execution.
And as I said, we want to
have a couple of other threads
that are also running on
the system at the same time.
So we might have a network
thread and a cleanup thread.
Now in this case, what
we are going to say
is that the yield procedure is
going to do these three steps.
And I made these steps a
little bit more concrete so
that we can actually
think about what
might be happening on the stack
as these things are executing.
So, the yield procedure
is going to, when it runs,
the first thing it's going
to do is save the state.
So to save the state, it
simply stores in this table
the stack pointer of the
currently executing program,
currently executing thread.
And then what it's
going to do is
it's going to pick the
next thread to run.
So in this case, picking
the next thread to run,
the thread scheduler is doing
something extremely simple.
It's just cycling through
all the available threads one
after another and
scheduling them, right?
So it says next gets next
plus one, and then modulo
the total number of threads
that are in the system.
So suppose num_threads
is equal to five.
As soon as next plus
one is equal to five,
and then five
modulo five is zero,
and we're going to
wrap that back around.
So, once we've executed
the fourth thread,
we are going to wrap
around and start
executing thread number zero.
And then finally
what it's going to do
is it's going to restore
the stack pointer.
Here, I'll just change
this for you right now.
This should be table sub next.
I didn't want to do that.
So, we have this table.
So, we restore the stack
pointer for the next thread
that we want to run from
the table of stack pointers
that are available.
And then what's
going to happen is
that when we exit out
of this yield routine,
we are going to load the return
address from the stack pointer
that we just have set up.
So you'll see how that
works again in a second.
But the basic process, then,
is just going to be as follows.
So this only works on
a single processor.
And I'm not going to have time
to go into too much detail
about what happens
in a multiprocessor,
but that book talks carefully
about why this doesn't work
on a single processor machine.
OK, so the basic process, then,
it's going to be as follows.
So we've got our
yield procedure.
We have our three threads.
Say we've numbered them
one, two, and three,
as shown up here.
So, num_threads
is equal to three,
and say we start off
with next equal to one.
So what's going to happen is
that the first thread at some
point it's going to
call a yield routine.
And what that's going
to do is it's going
to cause this yield to execute.
We're going to increment next.
And we're going to schedule
the network thread here.
OK, and the network
thread is going
to run for a little while.
And then at some point,
it's going to call yield,
and that's going to sort
of cause the next thread
to be scheduled.
We're going to call cleanup,
and then finally we're
going to call yield.
And the third thread is
going to call yield and cause
the first thread to run again.
And this process is
just going to repeat
over and over and over again.
OK, so --
OK, so what I want to do
now is to look at actually
more carefully at what's going
on with, how this scheduling
process is actually working.
So we can understand
a little bit better
what's happening to
the stack pointer,
and how these various yields
are actually executing.
So let's look at,
so this is going
to be an example of the stack
on, say, two of these threads,
OK?
So, suppose we have
thread number one.
I'll call this thread one,
and this is our Halo thread.
OK, and this is
the stack for Halo.
We also have thread number two,
which is our network thread.
OK, and this is also some stack
associated with this thing.
So we're just looking
at the current state
of the stack on these two
things, these two threads.
And if you remember,
typically we
represent stacks as
going down in memory.
So, these are the
different addresses
of the different entries
in the stack that
represent what's going on
currently in the processor.
So we'll say that thread
one, perhaps, the stack
starts at address 108,
and maybe thread two
starts at address 208.
OK, so suppose we
start up this system,
and when we start it
up, the stack pointer
is currently pointing here.
So we take a snapshot
of this system
at a given point in time.
Suppose the stack pointer is
currently pointing at 104.
The currently executing thread
is this one, thread one.
And we have, remember
our thread table
that captures the
current thread number,
and the saved stack pointer
for each one of these threads.
So we've got thread number
one, thread number two.
OK, so let's suppose we start
looking at this point in time
where the stack pointer
is pointing here.
And if we look at this
program, so if we start off
with the program that
we initially had,
in order to understand
what happens to the stack,
we need to actually look at
when the stack gets manipulated.
So if we are just
looking at C code,
typically the C code
isn't going to have,
we're not going to see the
changes to the stack occurring
within the C code.
So what I've done
here is in yellow,
I've annotated this with the
sort of additional operations,
the assembly operations, that
are happening on the entry
and exit to these procedures.
So what happens just before
we call the yield procedure is
that the Halo thread
will push the return
address onto the stack.
OK, so if we start executing
the yield procedure,
Halo is going to push the
return address onto the stack.
And then it's going to jump
into the yield procedure.
So, suppose we come onto here.
Now if we look at what
the return address is
after we execute
the yield procedure,
it's going to be
instruction number five.
So we're going to push
that address onto the stack
because instruction number
five is labeled here
on the left side is
where we're going
to return to after the yield.
And then the yield
is going to execute.
And what's going to happen
as the yield executes
is it's going to change
the stack pointer to be
the stack pointer of
the next thread, right?
So, I have this typo here again.
So be careful about that.
We're going to change
the stack pointer
to be the stack pointer
of the next thread.
And so when it executes
this pop RA instruction
that we see here,
it's actually going
to be popping the return
address from the network thread
that it scheduled next
as opposed to the return
address from this Halo thread.
OK, so suppose that the saved
stack pointer for the network
thread was pointing here at 204.
So, that would have been
an entry, 204, here.
And the saved return
address that it's going
to jump to is going to be here.
So suppose the return address
that it jumps to is 1,000, OK?
So if we look at the
state of these two threads
as they have been
running, we saw
thread one ran for
a little while,
and then it called yield, and
the instruction following yield
was instruction number five.
OK, so that was the
address that we pushed on
to the stack pointer.
Now, we switched over
here to thread two.
And last time we ran thread
two, it called yield,
and its return
address was 1,000.
So, there was this
1,000 here, OK?
So now, when we schedule thread
two, what's going to happen
is that we're going to read the,
so this is instruction 1,000.
We're going to start
executing from 1,000
because we're going to
execute this pop return
So we're going to pop the
return address off the stack,
and we're going to
start executing here
at instruction 1,000, OK?
So, you guys kind of see
how it is that we switch now
from one thread to the other,
by switching the stack pointer
and grabbing our return address
from the stack of thread two
instead of from thread one.
OK, so now what's
going to happen
is this thread two
is going to start
executing from this address.
And it's going to run
for a little while.
And at some point
later, it's going
to call yield again, right,
because it's run for a while
and it's decided that
it's time to yield.
So, suppose that instruction
1,024 it calls yield.
So when it does that, the
same thing is going to happen.
It's going to have run
for a little while.
So its stack is
going to have grown.
But eventually it's going
to push the return address
onto the stack, say
here 1,025, and suppose
this value of its stack
pointer now has grown down.
So it's gone 204.
It's run for a while, pushed
some things on the stack,
and maybe the stack
pointer is now at 148.
So, when it calls
yield, it's going
to write into the stack pointer
address in the thread table
148.
And we're going to restore
the stack pointer addressed
from here, which I forgot
to show being written in,
but what I should have
written in there was 104.
So, we're going to restore
the stack address to 104.
We're going to pop the next
instruction to execute off
of that stack five, and then
we're going to keep executing.
So you just switch back
and forth in this way.
OK, so -- --
what I want to do now is, so
this is the basic process now
whereby this yield
instruction can
be used to switch between
the scheduling of these two
procedures, right?
And this is sort of
the core of how it is.
So we have these two
threads of execution,
and they just sort
of run through.
And they periodically
call yield.
And that allows another thread
to be written, to execute it.
But otherwise these
threads have been
written in a style where
they don't actually
have to know anything about the
other threads that are running.
There could have been
two other threads
or 200 other threads running
on the system at the same time.
And this approach
that I showed you
would have caused all
those threads eventually
to have been scheduled
and to execute properly.
Right, but as we said
before, requiring
these functions to
actually call yield
periodically has
sort of defeated
the purpose of our
enforcing modularity, one
of our goals of
enforcing modularity,
which is to make it so that
no one thread can interfere
with the operation
of the other thread,
or cause that other
thread to crash, right,
because if the procedure
never calls a yield,
then a module never
calls yield, excuse me,
another thread will
never be scheduled.
And so, that module will have
the ability, essentially,
to take over the whole
computer, which is bad.
So what we're going
to look at now
is how we go from this
cooperative scheduling
where modules call yield
to preemptive scheduling
where modules are
forced to yield
the processor periodically.
OK, so this is the case where
you have no explicit yield
statements.
All right, so the idea
here is that turns out
to be very simple.
So programs aren't going
to have an explicit yield
statement in them.
But what we're
going to do is we're
going to have a special timer
that runs periodically within,
say, for example, the kernel.
So suppose the kernel has a
timer that runs periodically
that causes the kernel to be
sort of woken up and allowed
to execute some code.
So this timer is
going to be connected
to what's called an interrupt.
So, we're going to
introduce a timer interrupt,
and almost all
processors essentially
have some notion of
a timer interrupt.
And an interrupt is
something that when it fires,
it causes the processor to run
a special piece of code, OK?
So, basically this is
going to be some processor.
Think of it, if you like, as
some line on the processor.
OK, there's a wire that's
coming off the processor.
And when this wire gets pulled
high, when the timer goes off
and fires, this line is
going to be pulled high.
And when that happens,
the microprocessor
is going to notice
that and is going
to invoke a special
function within the kernel.
So this line is going to be
checked by the microprocessor
before it executes
each instruction, OK?
And if the line is
high, the microprocessor
is going to execute one of
these special gate functions.
So, we saw the notion
of a gate function
before that can be
used for a module
to obtain entry into the kernel.
Essentially what's
going to happen
is that when the
timer interrupt fires,
it's going to go execute one
of these special gate functions
as well.
And that's going to
cause the kernel to then
be in control of the processor.
So remember when the
gate function runs,
it switches the user to kernel
mode bit, to kernel mode.
It switches the page map address
register to the kernel's page
map so that the
kernel is in control,
and it switches the stack
pointer to the kernel's saved
stack pointer so that the kernel
is in control of the system,
and can execute whatever
code that it wants.
So this is going to accomplish
basically everything
that we need, right?
Because if we can get the kernel
in control of the system, now,
the kernel can do whatever it
needs to do to, for example,
schedule the next thread.
So the way that's going to
work is basically very simple.
So when the kernel
gets run, it knows
which thread, for example,
is currently running.
And basically what
it does is it just
calls the appropriate
yield function,
it calls the yield
function for the thread
that it's currently running,
forcing that thread to yield.
So, kernel calls yield
on current thread, right?
OK, so in order to
do this, of course
the kernel needs to
know how to capture
the state for the
currently running thread.
But for the most part
that's pretty simple
because the state
is all encapsulated
in the current values of the
registers in the current value
of the stack pointer.
So, the kernel is going to
call yield on the currently
executing thread,
and that's going
to force that thread to go ahead
and schedule another thread.
So the module itself
hasn't called yield,
but still the module has been
forced to sort of give up
its control the processor.
So, when it calls
yield, it's just
going to do it we
did before, which
is save our state and schedule
and run the next thread.
OK, so the only
last little detail
that we have to think about
is what if the kernel wants
to schedule a thread that's
running in a different address
space?
So if a kernel wants to
schedule a thread that's
running a different
address space,
it well, it has to do
what we saw last time when
we saw about how we
switch address spaces.
It has to change the
value of the PMAR register
so that the next address
space gets swapped
And then it can
go ahead and jump
into the appropriate
location in the sort of newly
scheduled address space.
So that brings us to the
next topic of discussion.
So, what we've seen so far
now, we saw cooperative
in the same address space,
and I introduced the notion
of a preemptive scheduling.
What we want to
look at now is sort
of what it means to run multiple
threads in different address
spaces.
Typically when we talk
about a program that's
running on a
computer or in 6.033
we like to call programs
running on computers processes.
When we talk about a process,
we mean an address space
plus some collection of threads.
So this is sort of
the real definition
of what we mean by process.
And alternately, you will
see processes called things
like applications or programs.
But any time you see a word
like that, what people typically
mean is some address space, some
virtual address space in which
we resolve memory addresses.
And then a collection of
threads that are currently
executing within
that address space,
and where each of
those threads includes
the set of instructions
and registers and stack
that correspond to it, OK?
So the kernel has explicit
support for these processes.
So in particular, what
the kernel provides
are routines to create a
process and destroy a process.
OK, and these create
and destroy methods
are going to sort of
do, the create method
is going to do all
the initialization
that we need to do in order
to create a new address space
and to create at least
one thread that is running
within that address space.
So we've sort of seeing
all the pieces of this,
but basically what
it's going to do
is it's going to
allocate the address
space in its table of
all the address spaces
that it knows about.
So we saw that in the
last time, and it's
going to allocate a
piece of physical memory
that corresponds to
that address space.
So, it's going to allocate
a piece of physical memory
that corresponds to
that address space.
It's going to allocate
one of these page maps
that the PMAR register
is going to point
to when this thing is running.
OK, and now the other
thing that it's going to do
is to go ahead and load
the code for this thing
into memory and map it
into the address space.
So it's going to add the code
for this currently running
module into the address space.
And then it's going to create
a thread for this new process.
And it's going to add it to
the table, the thread table,
and then it's going to set up
the value of the stack pointer
and the program counter
for this process
so that when the process
starts running it,
you sort of into the process at
some well-defined entry point,
say the main routine
in that process
so that the thread can
start executing at whatever
starting point it has.
OK, and now destroy
is just going
to basically do the opposite.
It's going to get rid of all
this state that we created.
So it's going to remove
the address space,
and it's going to remove
the thread from the table.
OK, and it may also
reclaim any memory
that's associated exclusively
with this process.
OK so if we look at --
So if you look at a computer
system at any one point
in time, what you'll see is
a collection of processes.
So I've drawn these
here as these big boxes.
So you might have a process
that corresponds to Halo
and, say, we are also
editing our code.
So, we have a process
that corresponds to emacs.
OK, and each one
of these processes
is going to have an address
space associated with it.
And then there are going
to be some set of threads
that are running in
association with this process.
So in the case of
Halo, I'm going
to draw these threads as
these little squiggly lines.
So in the case of Halo,
we saw that maybe it
has three threads that
are running within it.
So these are three threads that
all run within the same address
space.
Now, emacs might have just one
thread that's running in it,
say, although that's
probably not true.
emacs is horribly complicated,
and probably has many threads
that are running within it.
And so, we're going to have
these sort of two processes
with these two
collections of threads.
So if you think about
the sort of modularity
or the enforcement
of modularity that we
have between these
processes, we could
say some interesting things.
So first of all, we've
enforced modularity.
We have hard enforced modularity
between these two processes,
right, because there's no way
that the Halo process can muck
with any of the memory that,
say, the emacs process has
executed.
And as long as we're using
preemptive scheduling,
there's no way that the Halo
process could completely
maintain control
of the processor.
So the emacs process is
going to be allowed to run,
and its memory is going to
be protected from the Halo
process.
OK, now within the
Halo process, there
is sort of a different story.
So within the Halo
process, there
is sort of a different story.
So within the Halo
process, these threads,
because they are all within
the same address space,
can muck with each
other's memory.
So they are not isolated
from each other in that way.
And typically,
because these are all
within one process
in that if we were
to destroy that process in
this step, what the operating
system would do is in addition
to destroying the address
space, all of the
running threads.
So we say that these threads
that are running within Halo
share fate.
If one of them dies, or
if one of these threads
fails or crashes or
does something bad,
then they are
essentially all going
to crash or do something bad.
If the operating system
kills the process,
then all of these threads
are going to go away.
So this is the basic
picture of sort
of what's going on
within a computer system.
If you stare at this
for a little bit,
you see that there is actually
sort of a hierarchy of threads
that are running on
any one computer system
at any one point in time.
So we have these larger sorts
of processes that are running.
And then within
these processes, we
have some set of threads
that's also running, right?
And so, there is a diagram
that sort of useful
to help us understand
this hierarchy
or layering of processes or
threads on a computer system.
I want to show that to you.
OK, so on our computer system,
if we look at the lowest layer,
we have our
microprocessor down here.
OK, and this microprocessor,
what we've seen
is that the microprocessor
has two things
that it can be doing.
Either the microprocessor can
be executing, say, some user
program, or the
microprocessor can
be interrupted and go execute
one of these interrupt handler
functions.
So these interrupts are
going to do things like,
is going to be this
timer interrupt,
or when some IO device,
say for example the disk,
finishes performing some
IO operation like reading
a block from memory, then
the processor will receive
an interrupt, and the processor
can do whatever it needs
to do to service that
piece of hardware
so that the hardware
can go and, for example,
read the next block.
So in a sense, you can think
of the processor itself
as having two threads that
are associated with it.
One of them is an interrupt
thread, and one of them
is the main thread now
running on top of this.
So, these are threads
that are really
running within the kernel.
But on top of these things there
is this set of applications
like Halo and emacs.
And, these are the
kind of user programs
that are all running
on the system.
And there may be a
whole bunch of these.
It's not just two, but
it's any number of threads
that we can multiplex on
top of this main thread.
And then each one of
these may, in turn,
have sub-threads that are
running as a part of it.
So if you think about what's
going on in this system,
you can see that
at any one level,
these two threads don't
really need to know anything
about the other threads that
are running at that same level.
So, for example, within Halo,
these individual sub-threads
don't really know anything about
what the other sub-threads are
doing.
But it is the case that the
threads at a lower level
need to know about
the threads that
are running above them because
these threads at the lower
level implement this thread
scheduling policy, right?
So, the Halo program decides
which of its sub-threads
to run next.
So the Halo program
in particular is,
so the parent thread
implements a scheduling --
-- policy for all of
its children threads.
So Halo has some
policy for deciding
what thread to run next.
The operating system has some.
The kernel has some policy for
deciding which of these user
level threads to run next.
And the parent thread also
provides some switching
mechanism.
So we studied two
switching mechanisms today.
We looked at this notion of
having this sort of cooperative
switching where threads
call yield in order to allow
the next thread to run.
And, we looked at this notion
of preemptive scheduling
that forces the next thread
in the schedule to run.
So, if you look at
computer systems, in fact
it's a fairly
common organization
to see that there is preemptive
scheduling at the kernel
level that causes different
user level applications to run.
But within a particular
user program,
that program may use
cooperative scheduling.
So the individual
threads of Halo
may hand off control to the next
thread only when they want to.
And this sort of makes
sense because if I'm
a developer of a
program, I may very well
trust that the
other threads that I
have running in the
program at the same time,
I know I want them to run.
So, we can talk about sort of
different switching mechanisms
at different levels
of this hierarchy.
OK, so what we've
seen up to this point
is this sort of basic
mechanism that we
have for setting up a
set of threads that are
running on a computer system.
And what we haven't
really talked at all about
is how we can actually
share information
between these threads
or coordinate access
to some shared resource
between these threads.
So what I want to do with
the rest of the time today
is to talk about this
notion of coordinating
access between threads.
And we're going
to talk about this
in the context of a
slightly different example.
So -- --
let's suppose that I am
building a Web server.
And I decide that I
want to structure my Web
server as follows: I want
to have some network thread,
and I want to have some thread
that services disk requests.
OK, so the network
thread is going
to do things like accept
incoming connections
from the clients and
process those connections
and parse the HTTP requests
and generate the HTML results
that we send back to users.
And the disk request
thread is going
to be in charge of doing these
expensive operations where
it goes out to disk
and reads in some data
that it may need to
assemble these HTML
pages that we generate.
So, for next
recitation, you're going
to read about a system
called Flash, which
is a multithreaded Web server.
And so this should be a
little taste of what you're
going to see for tomorrow.
So, these two threads
are likely to want
to communicate with each
other through some data
structure, some
queue of requests,
or a queue of
outstanding information.
So suppose that what
we're looking at in fact
in particular is a
queue of disk blocks
that are being sent from
a disk request thread
out to the network thread.
So, whenever the disk
finishes reading a block,
it enqueues a value
into the network thread
so that the network thread can
then later pull that value off
and deliver it out to the user.
So in this case,
these are two threads
that are both running within
the same address space
within the same Web server.
So they both have direct access
to this queue data structure.
They can both read and write
to it at the same time.
This queue data structure, think
of it as a global variable.
It's in the memory that's
mapped in the address space
so both threads can access it.
So let's look at what happens
when these two threads, let's
look at some pseudocode that
shows what might be happening
inside of these two threads.
So, suppose within
this first thread
here, this network
thread, we have
a loop that says while
true, do the following.
De-queue a requestn
-- call it M --
from the thread,
and then process,
de-queue a disk block
that's in the queue
and then go ahead and
process that disk queue.
Go ahead and process that.
And now, within the
disk request thread,
we also have a while loop
that just loops forever.
And what this does is it gets
the next disk block to send,
however it does that, goes off
and reads the block from disk,
and then enqueues that
block onto the queue.
So if you like, you can think of
this as simply the disk request
thread is going to stick
some blocks into here,
and then the network
thread is going
to sort of pull those blocks
off the top of the queue.
So if you think about
this process running,
there's kind of a
problem with the way
that I've written
this, right, which
is that suppose that the
disk request thread runs much
faster than the network thread.
Suppose that for
every one network,
one block that the network
thread is able to pull off
and process, the disk thread
can enqueue two blocks.
OK, so if you think
about this for awhile,
if you run this system
for a long time,
eventually you're
going to have enqueued
a huge amount of stuff.
And typically the way
queues are implemented
is they are sort
of some fixed size.
You don't want them to grow
to fill the whole memory
of the processor.
So you limit them to some
particular fixed size.
And eventually we are going to
have the problem that the queue
is going to fill up.
It's going to
overflow, and we're
going to have a disk block
that we don't have anything
that we could do with.
We don't know what
to do with it.
Right, so OK, you
say that's easy.
There is an easy
way to fix this.
Why don't we just wait until
there is some extra space here.
So we'll introduce a
while full statement here
that just sort of
sits in a spin loop
and waits until this full
condition is not true.
OK, so as soon as the full
condition is not true,
we can go ahead and enqueue
the next thing on the queue.
And similarly we're going to
need to do something over here
on the process side
because we can't really
de-queue a message if
the queue is empty.
So if the processing
thread is running faster
than the enqueueing thread,
we're going to be in trouble.
So we're going to also need
to introduce a while loop here
that says something
like while empty.
OK, so this is fine.
It seems like it
fixes our problem.
But there is a little
bit of a limitation
to this approach, which
is that now what you see
is suppose these two
threads are running.
And they are being sort of
scheduled in round robin;
they are being scheduled
one after the other.
Now this thread runs.
And when it runs, suppose
that the queue is empty.
Suppose the producer hasn't
put anything on the queue yet.
Now when this guy runs,
he's going to sit here,
and for the whole time
that it's scheduled,
it's just going to
check this while
loop to see if the
thing is empty over,
and over, and over, and
over, and over again, right?
so that's all whole
lot of wasted time
that the processor
could and should
have been doing something
else useful like perhaps
letting the producer run so
that it could enqueue some data.
So in order to do this, so
in order to fix this problem,
we introduce this notion
of sequence coordination
operators.
And what sequence
coordination operators do
is they allow a
thread to declare
that it wants to wait until
some condition is true.
And they allow other threads to
signal that that condition has
now become true,
and sort of allow
threads that are waiting
for that condition
to become true to run.
So, we have these
two operations:
wait on some variable until
some condition is true,
and signal on that variable.
OK, so we're basically
out of time now.
So what I want to
do is I'll come back
and I'll finish going through
this example for the next time.
But what you should
do is think about,
suppose you had these sequence
coordination operators.
How could we sort of modify
these two while loops
that we have for these
two operators in order
to be able to take
advantage of the fact
that in order to be
able to make this
so we don't sit in this spin
loop forever and execute.
So that's it.
Today we saw how to get these
multiple processes to run
on one computer.
And next time we'll talk about
sort making computer programs
run more efficiently,
getting good performance out
of this sort of
architecture we've sketched.